apparently people really hate DeSantis
right now like there's videos of them
burning DeSantis Flags Trump supporters
are like no DeSantis and they're like
burning he was explaining why he
extended the state of emergency in
Florida and they're like why'd you do it
for so long a year and he said he was
explaining that he was actually able to
divert funds easier and force schools to
stay open and force them to not mask and
stuff because you could withhold funding
as long as he was in a state of
emergency if Ron was VP he'd be a 10 out
of 10 vice president if he's president
he's like a three out of ten oh yeah
even if I was like up to the last minute
if I was running and like I was the guy
that was going to be VPN DeSantis wanted
to do it I would step down for him
that's very honorable I think he's a
superior Governor to let Rhonda Sanders
be vice president yeah I think I think
in terms of the scale of presidentiality
Rhonda Santos is certainly on the scale
he is presidential but he's very very
low relative to Trump but in terms of VP
like that dude screams best VP